ارتفع عدد ضحايا الاعصار الذي يجتاح ولايه
اراكان فيما يانمار وجنوبي بنغلاديش الى
نحو 400 قتيل وقال مسؤولون محليون غربيه
ميانمار ان الاعصار مكتسبب ايضا باضرار
جسيمه في البنى التحتيه والممتلكات
وقطع التواصل مع مئات الاشخاص بالاضافه
الى حدوث انهيارات ارضيه في هذا السياق
حذرت الامم المتحده من ان مليوني شخص
يواجهون المخاطر نتيجه الاعصار
وقال منسق الشؤون الانسانيه في مكتب الامم
المتحده رومان فان بالا كريشنان ان اجتياح
الاعصار موكل للمناطق المعرضه سيلحق
اضرارا باكثر من خمسه ملايين واربعمائه
الف شخص
نتوقع ان يكون خمسه ملايين و400,000 شخص
في مسار الاعصار الذي يلقى رياحا تزيد
سرعتها على 90 كيلومترا في الساعه من بين
هؤلاء نعتبر ثلاثه ملايين شخص اكثر عرضه
لتاثيرات العاصفه من خلال جمع مؤشرات جوده
الماوى وانعدام الامن الغذائي وبالطبع ضعف
القدره على التكيف انه سيناريو مرعب حقا
ان يضرب الاعصار مناطق بها احتياجات ماسه
موجوده مسبقه